شخص موسوعي عالمي ناجح جميل جدا ببساطته
وتواضعه صاحب الوجه المبتسم والعاشق دائما
للمزيد من البحث والتعلم دون تعب او ملل
الدكتور فاروق الباز مدير مركز الاستشعار
عن بعد في جامعه بوسطن هو شخصيه الاسبوع
في مساء العربيه
[موسيقى]
في الفضاء هناك كويكب باسمه واطلق عليه
الاتحاد العالمي للفلك التابع للامم
المتحده لدوره البارز مع وكاله ناسا خاصه
مع رحلات ابولو يحرس خلال تدريبي رواد
الفضاء على انتقاء عينات مناسبه من احجار
القمر وتربته وشرحه بسيط كبساطته فيقول
عنه رائد الفضاء لبعثه ابولو 15
اتذكر شرحه للقمر فاشعر كما لو كنت هنا من
قبل وكذلك مع الصحفيين يسهل لهم التعابير
العلميه الدقيقه فهو دائما يصاحب فريق
النازه في المؤتمرات الصحفيه للاعلان عن
نتائج رحلات ابولو لم يكتفي الباز بدراسه
سطح القمر بل درس جوف الارض وكشفت ابحاثه
عن انهار عده مدفونه تحت رمال الصحاري
وتقديرا له انشات الجمعيه الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه جائزه سنويه اطلقوا عليها جائزه
فاروق الباز لابحاث الصحراء